[Music]
as you may know and hopefully should
know tomorrow is christmas eve normally
it's a time for church midnight mass
but because of the coronavirus a lot of
churches are adjusting their services
a few weeks ago a federal appeals court
reversed governor siselak's capacity
limits for all church services in nevada
originally the governor restricted
attendance to just 50 people to prevent
the spread of coven 19.
now churches can hold 25 percent
capacity
houses of worship must comply though
with protocols like social distancing
and temperature checks
catholic churches across las vegas are
holding mass
on thursday tomorrow for christmas eve
and on sunday in person
and streamed online in some cases i
think there is a
a pent-up longing for people
to come back to their houses of worship
uh to be together as a community
certainly to celebrate the birth of the
lord and i find that
our people are just wonderful and
they've been very resilient
uh really cooperative most catholic
churches are requiring members to make
reservations before attending mass and
services